[Musique]
c'est donc au moment où il tentait de
quitter le pays avec son épouse que le
président trahoré aurait été arrêté à
l'aéroport depuis on dispose d'ailleurs
d'aucune information précise sur son
sort portrait de cet homme qui dirigeait
le Mali depuis
1968 Jean-Paul
gerroir 4 jours des meutes sanglantes
ont finalement eu raison d'un des plus
anciens dictateurs du continent noir
Moussa Traoré un tyran africain
classique classique par son parcours par
ses soutiens par sa façon d'exercer le
pouvoir enfance paysane adolescence aux
enfants de troupe école militaire en
France retour au pays et PCH avec un
groupe d'officiers c'est en 1968 mousat
trouré dépose le premier gouvernement
malien issu de l'indépendance et impose
sa vision de la démocratie le parti
unique depuis les SCOR de ces
différentes réélection à la tête de
l'État ont varié entre 98 et 99,6 %.
lors du sommet franco-africain de La
Baule Moussa traor s'est fait notifier
comme les autres les nouveaux principes
de leur principal vailleur de fond la
France n'entendait plus protéger
indéfiniment ceux qui n'entameraient pas
un processus de démocratisation réponse
de Moussa traouré si le peuple estime
aujourd'hui demain que
cela que la gestion des affaires se
poursuive dans le parti unique ce sont
désir unique c'est son option et cela
constitue pour nous une forme de
démocratie sous la pression des hmetiers
il s'est finalement décidé à annoncer la
mise à l'étude du multipartisme
avanthier trop tard nouveau PCH fin de
parcours classique pour
mous les 12 ministres des Affaires é